okay so the Last of Us sent us around a
deadly infection caused by a fungi known
as the cordyceps these real world
parasites can often be found in nature
and what's most terrifying about the
last of us is that there is basis and
signs for something like this to happen
episode 1 of the HBO show opens with a
scientists theorizing the rise of them
all the way back in the 60s and like he
says there is no cure but where did the
infection originate from and how did it
spread so quickly well throughout this
video that's what we're going to be
breaking down and if you enjoy it please
hit the thumbs up button and don't
forget to subscribe for breakdowns like
this every day either way huge thank you
for clicking this now let's get into The
Last of Us
now when looking at where it all started
I think the first place to go is of
course the game the PlayStation classic
doesn't give too much of a backstory of
where it originated from but there are
teasers that can be found in documents
earlier when looking through newspapers
we come across the Texas Herald which
report on the infection on September 26
it said that admittance at hospitals was
up 300 and this was all due to a
mysterious infection the FDA also
released a statement about contaminated
crops and they said that massive records
were expected this of course didn't
happen but the statement did give us a
clue about what was really going on it
said the Food and Drug Administration
investigation of crops potentially tated
with mold continues across the country
initial lists distributed a vendors
Nationwide won against crops imported
from South America but now the scope has
extended to include Central America and
also Mexico so there are Clues here that
it's coming from countries with a hotter
climate this was teased at in the
initial science report at the start in
2003's listed as being being one of the
hottest years on record although it's
not in South America we do hear reports
in episode 1 that there's something
strange going on in Jakarta this
Indonesian city is located in Asia and
they might have changed this from South
America for us to explore it in a later
episode during filming of the show
people from Jakarta posted that things
were being filmed in the city so we
could possibly see this coming down the
line at some point and in easier
actually houses the largest bread and
Flower Factory in the world so this
could be the reason the country was
chosen to be the place it's housed
anyway I think the show will likely
follow the same route and there were
several clues in the episode that this
was attached to food products with flour
in them firstly we saw Mrs Adler on her
drive being fed it and she later became
one of the main infected people that
Sarah encountered Joel also said But I'm
on Atkins
what now this is a diet that's low carb
and because of this he'd be avoiding
foods like bread and so on I know it was
said it's a joke yeah before you start
but Atkins was brought up I think for a
specific reason now this date was also
his birthday but the pet never had a
cake which would also contain the
ingredients Tommy was guttered that they
weren't having pancakes that morning and
they had bacon and eggs instead of
things like cereal now another big clue
came when Sarah went to Mrs Adler I was
thinking we'd make some cookies
chocolate chip Frozen
okay
she was baking cookies which would
include the ingredients but because they
were raisin Sarah didn't end up eating
them now this might not be the case but
the episode constantly kept hammering
home the idea that they were avoiding
food all the time and those that ended
up infected of course ended up eating it
food being contaminated with cordyceps
could explain how the virus managed to
spread so quickly especially if it was
located in foods that people regulate
flour is in a lot of products and if it
got into this then it could easily
spread across the planet the game
details that once the outbreak had
happened that 60 of humanity had either
become infected or died within a couple
of months the cordyceps can of course be
passed on through bites and in the game
we have the spores as well this would
massively push it across the planet and
mean that the infection could spread
really quickly now as for the real life
inspiration there's actually a similar
case that happened during the 50s in Pon
sanes spreed a mass poisoning happened
in which more than 250 people were
infected by food this was an illness
that saw bread being infected by ergot
which is a fungus that grows on rye this
parasite spread onto the bread and nuts
into the food chain which is where it
was picked up by the mass population at
a bakery the fungus contaminate the food
and this was then ate by the civilians
that lived in the neighboring Villages
it brought on illness and in some rare
cases even Insanity it took months for
it all to build up and there were Bakers
who suspected that something was in the
flower they named it cursed bread and
those who ate it had fits of vomiting
and also diarrhea more than 50 people
were interned at an asylum and the way
that the infected go crazy in the last
of us could be inspired by this now
there weren't any people going around
becoming zombies and and biting people
but there were some very very strange
occurrences a man hallucinate that he
was an airplane and he jumped from his
second story window which ended up
killing him as the sign is mentioned in
episode 1 LSD is created using fungus so
it's easy to see how this happened in
addition to this an 11 year old boy
attempted to strangle his own mother and
lashed out in a violent rage brought on
by the parasite later doctors named this
the Nuit apocalypse which translates to
apocalyptic night which I hope I
pronounced right now it's so chilling to
hear stories like this and you can see
how real-life occurrences couldn't have
been sparring what we see in the gaming
show the main thing with the cordyceps
is that they attach to your brain and
the parasites begin to override the
amount of functions this is why we see
people twitching and lashing out at
others the person is still in there
which is why the in fact it can often be
found crying but they don't have control
over their desires anymore and will
attack all those that they see who
aren't infected now in the case of the
yogurt poisoning the grains were
inspected by the government's control
board they enforce rules in which it was
difficult to purchase products
containing flour and the people were
very much put on wartime shortages the
factory was charged with involuntary
manslaughter and an employee ended up
being arrested it was found in an
inquiry that the flower Mill in the area
had been cutting Corners which if you're
gonna start off a zombie apocalypse it
always happens because of that now it
turns out they've been mixing Ryan with
a flower in order to be able to cut the
amount of flour that they were using it
also been using the leftover piles that
tend to be on the ground and beside the
machines sometimes they were sat there
for weeks and these were proud to get
infected with mites in ergot just all
around unsanitary conditions and this
led to this becoming a much bigger
problem people would charge for it and
all in all it became a pretty big story
in the area if it's all connected to a
food source I can definitely see this
being something that's LinkedIn and it
is possible this ties in with how the
infections spread I don't know if you've
seen goth meringue before but I'll play
the clip in a bit that I think basically
sums up episode one it's an episode
where water gets infected with something
that turns people into apes and you have
a bit where some characters hilariously
avoid drinking it by pure luck morning
Dad morning thoughts and read good
morning remember if you took like a
glass of water no thanks I'll have a
coffee thanks Sir George lover glass
it's run out here have mine no closed
captioning
not
available
here you go cheers
just something I thought of when going
back and watching episode one and seeing
people be like I'll not have the cookies
I'll actually have the bacon and eggs
hopefully hopefully they can get a shot
which can help cure themselves not that
kind of shot dear me and that's the
video which I hope you learned something
in I think the show will probably adapt
this into the food stuff as it's in the
game and they do seem to be sticking
pretty closely this Source material let
me know below what you think and if you
have any other theories I'd absolutely
love to hear them now we are in
competition right now and giving away
wakanda forever to three subscribers on
the 15th of February and all you have to
do to be when the chance of winning is
like the video make sure you subscribe
with notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts and theories we
pick the comments at random at the end
of the month and we pick the comments at
random at the end of the month and the
winners of the last one are on screen
right now similar to you then message me
on Twitter at heavy spoilers if you want
something else to watch then make sure
you check out our breakdown of the
trailer for episode 2 which will be
linked on screen right now lots of
things going on in it lots of theories
and yeah definitely head over there
right after this by the way thanks for
sticking through the video I've been
poor I'll see you next time take care
peace